un mago presentando su espectáculo de
magia en una fiesta de cumpleaños se
coloca dentro de un círculo de 15 niños
él va a escoger un voluntario y quiere
que cada niño tenga la misma oportunidad
de ser escogido bien ahora tenemos tres
métodos con los que puede hacerlo y sólo
pensemos en si estos métodos son justos
si cada niño tiene la misma posibilidad
de ser escogido y si no y si no nos
llevan a que todos los niños tengan la
misma posibilidad de ser escogidos
piensan en porque es así método 1
el mago empieza con el niño que cumple
años y se mueve en sentido horario
repartiendo 100 pedazos de papel
numerados del 1 al 100 el da vueltas
alrededor del círculo hasta que todos
los pedazos están distribuidos y luego
usa un generador de números al azar para
escoger un entero entre 1 y 100 y escoge
el voluntario con ese número pensemos en
lo que está pasando aquí así que hay
de niños en un círculo entonces hay 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 así que
hay 15 niños en un círculo y va a
repartir los pedazos de papel así que va
a
va a repartir 1 2 3 4 5
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 y luego esta
persona va a obtener los pedazos del 1 y
el del 16 esta persona tendrá el 2 y él
17 y seguiremos dando vueltas y vueltas
hasta que todos los 100 pedazos de papel
estén distribuidos ahora una cosa en la
que tenemos que pensar es si cada niño
tendrá el mismo número de pedazos de
papel y te invito a que pases el vídeo y
pienses en ello
si seguimos dando vueltas hasta llegar
al 100 los niños obtendrán la misma
cantidad de pedazos de papel
sólo pensamos en eso para que cada niño
tenga el mismo número de pesos de papel
quién debe de ser divisible entre 15 y
sabemos que 100 no es divisible entre 15
15 cabe en 100
seis veces seis veces 15
y tienes un residuo de
y lo que va a pasar aquí es que todos
los 15 niños tendrán 6 pedazos de papel
y luego 10 de los 15 obtendrán un
séptimo pedazo de papel por lo que no
todos están obteniendo un número igual
de pedazos de papel así que aunque esté
eligiendo un número al azar entre 1 y
100 algunos de los niños van a tener
mayores posibilidades que otros los 10
que tienen 7 pedazos de papel tendrán
mayores posibilidades que los otros 5
que solo tienen 6 pedazos que sólo
tienen 6 pedazos de papel por lo que yo
diría que el método 1
el método 1 no es justo y déjame lo
escribo no
no justo
y si algunas veces la vida es injusta
pero en este caso no es justo y tenemos
que encontrar el ser justo como la misma
probabilidad de ser elegido y eso es
porque no todos tienen y todos tienen un
número diferente de pedazos de papel no
todos los niños tienen la misma
probabilidad de ser elegidos así que
veamos el método post
el mago comienza con el niño que cumple
años y se mueve en sentido antihorario
repartiendo 75 pedazos de papel
numerados del 1 al 75 el da vueltas
alrededor del círculo hasta que todos
los pedazos son distribuidos el después
usa un generador de números al azar para
escoger un entero del 1 al 75 y escoge
al voluntario con ese número y te invito
a pausar el vídeo y pensar si este el
método 2 si este es justo bueno el
método 2 es igual al método 1 pero en
lugar de utilizar 100 pedazos de papel
estamos utilizando 75 pedazos de papel
lo que tenemos que pensar ahora es si 75
es divisible entre 15 y 75 lo es 5 veces
15 es 75
en esta situación cada niño obtendrá
seis pedazos de papel todos obtienen
obtienen
pedazos de papel así que todos tienen
oportunidades igualmente probables de
ser elegidos y luego usa un generador de
números al azar para elegirlos por lo
que todos tienen oportunidades
igualmente probables por lo que diría
que el método 2 es
el método 2 este hecho
este hecho justo
todos tienen la misma oportunidad de ser
elegidos ahora pensemos en el método 3
el método 3
el mago empieza con el niño que cumple
años y se mueve en sentido horario
repartiendo 30 pedazos de papel
numerados del 1 al 30 así que todos
tendrán el mismo número de pedazos de
papel todos tendrán dos pedazos de papel
si cada uno de los 15 niños tiene dos
pedazos de papel serán 30 pedazos de
papel eso se ve razonable hasta ahora el
de vueltas alrededor del círculo hasta
que todos los pedazos son distribuidos
así que todos tienen dos pedazos el edad
el número uno al niño que cumple años el
número dos al siguiente niño y así
sucesivamente todo esto suena razonable
parecido al método 2 pero ahora en vez
de 75 son 38 75 estaba sobrado incluso
aquí está sobrado 30 sólo necesita 15
pedazos de papel realmente
y luego cuenta el número de ventanas en
la habitación y escoge al voluntario con
ese número la pregunta aquí es si el
número de ventanas en la habitación es
al azar y si está distribuido
equitativamente entonces tal vez tal vez
puedas hacer un caso en el que
dependiendo del edificio en el que estén
la casa de alguien sea algo al azar
cuantas ventanas tenga esa casa la casa
en donde se está celebrando la fiesta de
cumpleaños pero no va a ser igual no va
a estar distribuida equitativamente
no lo sé quizá haya quizá allá ya saben
quizá hayan y si vas a todas las casas
en donde hacen fiestas de cumpleaños
verás que es más probable que tengan
diez ventanas a una ventana o
definitivamente es más probable que
tengan diez ventanas
digamos 30 ventanas o incluso hasta 15
ventanas por lo que no estará
distribuida de una manera equitativa
esto la verdad no es
este es ya sabes cada casa tiene un
número un número diferente de ventanas y
la casa que tenga la casa en donde se
está haciendo la fiesta parece haberse
elegido al azar pero no va a estar
distribuida de manera equitativa aquí y
yo diría que este no es muy buen
generador de números al azar porque no
está generando de manera equitativa por
lo que diría que el método 3 no es justo
no
justo
el número de ventanas no es un muy buen
generador de números al azar un buen
generador es elegir al azar
del 1 al 75 en donde cualquiera de estos
tienen posibilidades igualmente
probables de ser elegidos esto es de
alguna manera al azar el número de
ventanas pero
no todas son igualmente igualmente
posibles